Mary John, welcome to the show.
Thank you for having me. Uh, I I'm, I,
I'm going to start by asking you, what, what makes you a typical Trump?
A typical Joe. Oh, wow. I don't think, um,
I don't know that I have anything in common with anybody in my family, honestly.
Uh, that's a fascinating question.
I I've never really thought about it because in some ways I've always felt so
outside of them because my interests has always been so different,
uh, like across the board, uh, politically, intellectually,
um, you know, I like to read for example, so I,
I honestly don't think I have anything in common with,
uh, anybody left in my dad's family, which I think is a good thing,
honestly.
But you do have the genes after all?
Uh, yeah. Well, there is a family resemblance that I cannot deny. So.
I was, I, I should be honest to say that I was expecting,
uh, a bit more, uh, what should I say? Uh, uh,
lavish interiors and gold-plated, uh, you know,
gold.
Uh, it's true that, um,
my grandfather was enormously wealthy and could have
afforded as extravagant lifestyle as he wanted,
but he was also a very provincial person. Um,
first of all, his GRA,
his mother was a very austere person and,
um, he also lived through the depression. So I think there was,
um, a reticence about, uh, being lavish in any way.
So, uh,
at least compared to other people with his wealth, he lived pretty modestly.
Actually, I, I didn't understand when I was a kid,
just how much money my family had.
So, so as they, after all, they,
they were quite wealthy. Uh, how, how, how would Christmas be there?
I, it was, it was probably the most extravagant,
uh, occasion during the year. Um,
we had it at my grandparents' house there. It was, uh, there was a, uh, around,
um, what do you call it? Uh, entryway.
And I'm so sorry about this. And it was like a 30 foot ceiling.
So every Christmas my grandfather would like a 25 foot Christmas tree,
but my grandmother would decorate it. Like she would get on a ladder, you know,
she would put the lights on herself, so she had no help.
So on the one hand it was a very overdone,
but on the other hand,
it was just my grandmother doing it single-handedly so,
you know, they didn't know how to enjoy, uh,
their wealth at all.
W w w what about gifts?
Um, well, they were terrible gift givers. I have to say. Um,
Donald and his first wife Ivana were the worst.
So basically everybody in my family had to give everybody else a gift.
So I had to give all of my aunts and uncles gifts. And so it was ridiculous.
Like there would be dozens and dozens and dozens of packages under the tree.
And since nobody really put a lot of thought into it,
nobody ever got anything that really suited them necessarily, you know,
we would get clothes that were the wrong size or, um,
you know,
we would get something that was of no interest to us whatsoever, but,
you know, Donald and Ivana took it to a whole new level. Um, Avanto for example,
was famous for re gifting. So in other words,
she would get a gift from somebody or get something from a luncheon.
She had attended rewrap it,
and then give it to somebody else with Christmas present a one year,
the very first year she was in the family.
She gave me a three pack of underwear, which,
you know, I could use obviously,
but it wasn't exactly a great Christmas present. So, um,
it was sometimes hard not to feel insulted, but my brother and my older cousin,
and I, we just sort of made a joke out of it because, you know,
what are you going to do?
Uh, your, your grandfather was, was Donald Trump's father. Uh,
I, um, how close would you say you were to him?
To my grandfather. Yeah.
Right. Not at all. Um,
partially because my grandfather had no use for girls.
Um, but mostly because he, um,
did not like my mother, my, uh, my dad's wife, obviously,
and he did not respect or care for my father who
was, uh, his oldest son either. So I kind of suffered from,
from being their child as well. Uh, so he was,
he was pretty dismissive of me, uh, throughout the course of my life.
And it wasn't, uh,
it wasn't until he had actually forgotten who I was after he developed
Alzheimer's that he actually started being kind to me.
So how, how about how his, his wife w were you close?
I actually was very close with my grandmother eventually. Um,
not really when I was a kid because, uh, I don't know. We just, you know, we,
it wasn't an affectionate family and I was at their house all the time,
but we didn't really have a lot of conversations
necessarily, but a few years after my dad died,
I felt that it was my responsibility to be in her life or to have her in my
life. So I made a, I made a real effort and we got to be very, very close.
Um,
I'd say in the maybe four years after my dad died
until my grandfather died. Uh, so, you know, I,
I saw her two or three times a week. We talked on the phone every day.
So how well would you say that you got to know your uncle,
the precedent.
The thing about Donald is that there's not much to know. Uh,
he is literally exactly the same when he's in front of a
camera as he is when he's with his family or
when he's with the people he works with. So when that's the case,
there really isn't much underneath the surface.
Um, so when I worked for him, he hired me in 90,
I think it was 1993 to write his third book for him.
And that was really the first time as an adult that I spent that much time with
him. I saw him every day. Um, and we traveled together sometimes.
And, um,
it was remarkable how little I got to know
him, because as I said,
there just wasn't that much to know what you see with Donald is pretty much what
you get.
Why, why do you think he wanted you to write that book?
Um,
because I went to Tufts university and I had
written a letter to the Dean of students recommending one of my
professors for tenure. And after I graduated,
the Dean sent this letter to Donald basically to say, look,
ma Mary loves Tufts so much. It was sort of a fundraising ploy. Right.
But when Donald read the letter,
what he saw was that I was really good at complimenting people.
So he thought that that would be a views, uh,
in somebody who wrote his next book.
Um.
Your, the way you describe your grandfather,
it must have been kind of a tough upbringing for your
father, Fred, the older brother, and also for, for Donal. Uh,
but they, they dealt very differently with that upbringing.
Yeah.
Was it a very difficult household to grow up in? And,
um, I think all of the children, all five of them suffered,
but particularly my dad, because he was the oldest son,
he was the namesake. He was supposed to take over the empire.
And from a fairly young age,
I imagine my grandfather saw things in my dad. He did not admire,
um, you know, he wasn't tough. It was actually quite sensitive. He was kind,
he was funny and he had interests outside of real estate.
You know, he loved boats and fishing and he went on to be, become a pilot.
And, uh,
because he didn't fit the mold of what my grandfather expected him to be.
He punished him very severely. Um,
my dad was subjected to lots of humiliation growing up and,
um, you know, Donald witnessed this cause he was seven and a half years younger.
The difference was that eventually to
protect himself really from the same kinds of abuse,
my dad got Donald developed personality traits, uh,
that, you know, most people wouldn't admire. Um, you know,
he was a bully. He would do anything to win, including lying, cheating,
and stealing what my grandfather actually did value those characteristics.
So they kind of became hardened and, you know, that's,
that's why we see how Donald is today. Honestly.
So, so, so in your view, how,
how do you think he might respond to losing? I mean, if that's going to happen.
Very badly, uh, you know, we, we need to be really,
clear-eyed about what might happen. First of all,
he's going to do anything in his power to make sure that doesn't happen. Uh,
and we already see he's cheating already. Um, you know,
by telling people that it isn't safe to vote by mail in the middle of a
pandemic by telling people that if Joe Biden wins, it,
it will have been rigged. You know, that's cheating, uh,
because he's using the power of the oval office to get that message across
if however, uh, Giovanna does win. Um,
it kind of depends on the margin of victory,
if it's a huge landslide and nobody can pretend that it's an illegitimate
result. I think Donald is much more likely to try to spin it as
America's loss. You know,
he was the best thing that ever happened to this country and we don't deserve
him. So he's going to go do something really important,
like build Trump tower in Moscow or something, if it's close,
I think we're in for a very, very rough period of time.
You you've you've, uh, go call them a narcissist. And, uh,
and as you are the psychologist, uh,
I must ask you why, how, how can you give him, uh, uh,
diagnosed without even treating him?
I actually don't diagnose him, uh,
because it's technically impossible to diagnose somebody who is not your
patient. You know, it requires a very specific procedure, uh,
which he wouldn't submit to, and he's not my patient. So what I,
what I try to do in the book is help people understand how many
symptoms he has, uh, various personality disorders.
So, um,
people can see just how complex is psych
psychopathology is, are because, you know,
I think the diagnosis isn't really that important.
It's his behavior that we need to pay attention to.
And if you look at his behavior, you can see that this is not a well person.
Um, would you, um, w w if,
if he were to, to, to lie on your coach, what would you ask him?
Uh,
but it's so hard for me to imagine his ever putting himself in that position.
Um, you know, I would honestly
I'd ask him to start at the beginning because that's what we do. Um,
but I'm not entirely sure we
could get anywhere because somebody with his kinds of disorders,
when they do go to therapy, which is rare,
they claim that the problem is everybody else, you know,
they're perfectly fine,
but it's the rest of the world that's causing them grief.
It's the rest of the world.
That's making impossible for them to function properly. So, um,
you know, I, I, you know,
one question I might ask him is what are you so
afraid of?
And it would be very difficult if not impossible for him to acknowledge that,
but I continued to believe that Donald's biggest
problem is that deep down, he is a terrified little boy,
and he's never gotten.
W what kind of experience do you have with them that makes you say that?
Well, you know, I've known him my whole life and I've,
I've seen how things have unfolded,
but I also have access to family history. You know, um,
I have stories. I was, as I said, close with my grandmother,
I wasn't one time close with one of my aunts. Um, my dad died when I was 16,
but, you know, I still had plenty of stories from him as well,
and other people who knew the family.
So I can say that with confidence in part,
because, um,
it is factually true that my grandmother became very,
very ill when Donald two and a half,
and was essentially absent from his life for about a year.
I know that my grandfather was a sociopath and was incapable
and unwilling to take over her role. So for about a year,
this toddler had nobody to sooth
him, had nobody to be affectionate,
had nobody to tell him that he didn't need to be afraid,
but there was nothing done after that to repair those wounds.
It only got worse. Uh, that's a very,
very terrible time in a child's life to be abandoned by the one
person in the world who is, you know, your main human connection.
And Mariam. I'm sure you're aware of, of, uh, of the precedent tweeting, uh,
about you and your book, uh, and, uh, among all the things he wrote that,
uh, he,
he describes you as a seldom see niece who knows little
about me,
says untruthful things about my wonderful parents who couldn't stand her.
What's your comment on that?
I'm not entirely sure why he thought that that would make me look bad, but,
you know, he seems to forget that, uh, if I'm his niece, he's also my uncle.
And, um,
I think he also said that I was unloved from the moment I was born,
which I'm not entirely sure what I did when I was an infant to make people
not love me. But again, it's just, it's a,
it's a commentary on him and his parents,
if that were indeed the case. Um,
so as often happens with Donald,
he lashes out in a way that ends up hurting him. Um,
and also I, he can say whatever he wants to about me, it doesn't,
it doesn't have any impact on me,
but I found it a curious line of attack.
He would have been better served if he just ignored me in the book entirely.
Do you.
You are, I know you that you are in the middle of a lawsuit. Uh,
w w where do your family, and also you, you written this book. I mean, do you,
do you at one level feel that you have betrayed them willingly?
No. Uh, because they were never loyal to me.
It's I don't see how you can betray people who
were never there for you in any capacity that mattered. And it's interesting,
like I don't ever hear anybody asking him that question about whether or not he
betrayed me, so I don't see it that way. I see,
I wrote the book mostly as an American citizen, uh,
as somebody who's deeply concerned about what's happening in my country,
the lawsuit is really, um,
a way of getting justice. These were my aunts and uncles who,
after my dad died at the age of 42 committed financial fraud
against me,
and kept me out of my fair share out of my dad's inheritance.
So I see the lawsuit as, um,
a way to get my stolen property returned to me, quite honestly.
Um, I want to, because I'm sitting here with, with, uh,
a TV anchor that has covered many precedents.
I just wonder when you hear this, the, my, my,
my interview with, with, uh, Mary, uh, Clawson, what, what are your thoughts?
Well, I think a lot about it. Uh, it's a one-sided story, of course,
because it's, it's one person against the rest of the family,
but I wanted more Mary what's happening to you after you published the book,
how are people treating you?
Um, and I agree with you, of course, it's, it's, it's one sided, but I,
I will say though,
that it's backed up by family history and stories,
I was able to get from other people. Um, but you're right. It's,
it's decidedly my point of view.
So I encourage everybody to take it with a grain of salt, if necessary, uh,
in terms of what it's been like after the book came out,
you know, we're, we're on lockdown because of COVID. So in a really weird way,
nothing's changed. Um, I mean,
I get to have interesting conversations via zoom with people
I've never met before, so that's great, but, um, you know,
I'm still in my house. Um,
I'm I live in New York and we got hit very, very hard.
So I've not really ventured out very much, uh,
since March. Um,
so it's a little, uh, I mean,
I was going to say frustrating, but, you know,
so many people are so much worse off than I am, but, you know,
in a small way, it's frustrating that it it's,
it's hard for me to gauge how the book's been received if it's
having any kind of impact. Um, but the,
the extent to which my life hasn't changed at all is kind of remarkable.
And it's because of COVID.
Do you have any contact with, with anyone in the family now?
I don't. And I didn't anticipate that I would, and I understand that. I mean,
why should they want to have contact with me? Um,
I think that's completely a completely fair response, but, you know,
I also went into this with my eyes wide open. Uh,
these are vindictive people and, you know,
I had to take the necessary precautions because like, it or not,
Donald does have a lot of power and he does have a lot of followers.
So, uh, you know,
I've been in a way COVID has also made it easier for me to be careful. Okay.
What, uh, hello. Um, when I was 17,
I was an exchange student in North Dakota. You should go there.
It's a very lovely place. Uh, the friends from high school there,
uh,
that's my focus group in the U S and they think Trump is going to win because
they don't like, uh, communism. So, uh,
what if the polls are wrong again?
Oh, well, I mean,
that's why I don't sleep anymore because we're all still traumatized from
2016. Um, you know,
it's interesting in a terrifying way, um,
that people in North Dakota are still able to have that attitude when
first of all, Joe Biden is as far from a communist,
as you can get and, you know, still be a Democrat. I mean,
I am so far to the left of Joe Biden.
It's amazing that anybody can try to
pin the label of socialist or communist on him. And I think it's,
it's a condemnation of our system of education that people don't even
understand what these terms mean. Um, but beyond that, uh,
I don't know if you, you have seen the numbers recently,
North Dakota is on fire with COVID-19
infections right now. It's absolutely horrifying.
I mean, they have the highest rate of infection.
I think in the world right now is like 76 per a hundred thousand.
It's through the roof,
it's a straight line up and there's only one
person to blame for this.
And yet they're worried that Joe Biden might be a communist it's, um,
it's very concerning because I think it does suggest that there's
a possibly a stronger possibility than there might
otherwise have been, uh, that Donald has a shot at it.
I hope that's not the case, but you know,
it's something we need to take very seriously.
Mary. I know you've been generous with your time.
I just have two more questions. I'm one that's from Leumi.
Um, sure. So we were, hi, it's it's, uh, an honor to meet you.
And you did ask if you think your book have some kind of impact than it does,
you know, we in Europe has been a lot of conversations about you and your book,
so it's definitely creating waves. Um, but we just,
before you came on, we were talking about, um,
advice and who you would take advice from, and who would you give advice to?
Who, who, who guided you,
who made you become a person that has the bravery and the strength
to go against and stand up for something in,
in a situation where it's quite scary, must be quite scary.
For you?
Uh, well, first of all, thank you for that. I really appreciate it. Um,
and secondly, I think there,
I think I'm missing something because it didn't feel like it took courage to do
this. It felt like something I had to do. I had an obligation,
I had information that could help the American people understand the danger
we're in, um, and it just needed to be done,
you know, um, because also, like I think of bravery and I think of,
of,
of people who take their families pack up everything they own and
travel thousands of miles across hostile territory to seek refuge in a country
that then rejects them. You know, that's courage,
courage in America to me is being a person of color raising a black
child. Uh, you know, so I guess I,
I kind of just compare what I I've done to things like that.
And it doesn't seem like it really took that much courage
and I'm actually not afraid because, um,
despite the fact that Donald is in a position of power,
I've known him forever and he's the weakest person I've ever known.
So it just, it's impossible for me to be afraid of him.
Where finally, when was the last time you met her?
I was at the white house, uh,
in April of 2017 for my aunt's birthday parties. Uh,
so that's,
that's the last time I saw him and the time before that was
eight years earlier and my cousin Ivanka's wedding and then eight years before
that, uh, because the lawsuit kind of makes it when you Sue your family,
it kind of makes it difficult to keep having holidays.
Describe that, describe that,
that last meeting you had with him at the white house, how was that?
It was actually kind of fascinating in a way. Um,
it was very stressful, but, um, when I first saw,
you know, we, we had a tour,
but I didn't see Donald until we got to the dining room and he was standing in
the entryway. And when he saw me,
he pointed at me and he smiled and he said,
I specifically asked for you to be invited,
which was a lie. Um,
but it tells you so much about his psychology because
he knew it was a lie. He probably knew I knew,
but he one wanted to take credit for it. And two,
it was actually charming, right? Like if I had believed him,
I would have been entirely charmed by that. So, uh,
I thought that was fascinating that he hadn't changed a bit since I'd last
seen him not surprisingly.
And this is what you were I'm so sorry.
Was that a surprise to him that you came? Did he know?
He looked surprised, but I don't know.
I don't know if he saw the list ahead of time or not. I would assume he did.
So I'm not sure why he looked as surprised as he did, but it was an odd moment.
And he also, for the very first time in my life hugged me,
which was also kind of shocking. Um, and then at the very end,
after the meal and we were taking pictures with him, uh,
I said to him, and this was very early on in the administration,
but things were already going badly. Um, so I said to him,
don't let them get you down. And he clenched his teeth and he said,
they're not going to get me. Um,
and so far he's, uh, been right.
Why, why do you think you said that.
I wanted to get under his skin a little bit? Honestly,
I don't know. I mean, I didn't plan it. It just kind of happened.
So I've often thought about that too. Why did I say that to him? Um,
I think it was a way to get under his skin without,
without appearing to be aggressive about it, you know?
Um, but I'm, I'm still not sure,
but his answer was kind of perfect and it wasn't just what he said.
It was the way he said it and the way he clenched his draw. Uh,
so even then I could see that he was under the kind of stress that he'd
never been in in his life.
Um, I'm so grateful that you, you found the time to talk to us from New York.
Um, if you were to say one nice thing about your uncle before we wrap up,
what would that be?
Uh, first of all, I hope you guys will let me move there.
If things don't go well in November, that would be great. Um,
in all serious, no seriousness though. Um,
and this isn't something I enjoy saying. I can't think of one thing.
Well, then, uh, we'll have to leave it at that.
Thank you very much. And, uh, um, the, what should I say?
Good night and good luck.
You too. Thank you. This was wonderful. It was great to meet all of you.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible] hope you enjoyed the clip for more interesting conversations,
please hit subscribe.